mon ancien patron il venait me voir dans
les bars le week-end quand je jouais
avec mon groupe est d'ailleurs il me
prêtait souvent les véhicules de la
société pour qu'on puisse amener la
batterie iv
l'ampli basse et c est un moment qui est
hyper beau qui à force de me voir dans
les bars le week-end il comprenait pas
pourquoi le lundi matin à 6 heures
j'étais quand même là sur les chantiers
à à bosser il a fait un geste qui était
hyper symbolique et parfois pour moi ce
qui m'a licencié au début évidemment
j'ai pas vraiment compris j'ai je me
sentais fautif et il m'a juste expliqué
que s'il le faisait c'était pour me
permettre de me laisser quelques mois
devant moi pour essayer de trouver ma
voie dans la musique semaines après je
crois il ya eu ce casting à marseille
c'est complètement fou parce qu'aussi
bien s'il m'avait pas dit ça comme ça
s'il m'avait pas viré de la société où
je me sentais très bien mais si j'avais
bossé ce jour là non je serai pas à
lille en plus à l'époque faut quand même
imaginer que la nouvelle star c'était
stebig et que la file d'attenté s'était
c'étaient les premières auditions
donc les premières auditions dans les
villes donc c'était je suis pas agent 4
5 heures des milliers des milliers de
personnes qui faisaient la file
d'attenté s'était c'était vraiment
impressionnant
[Musique]
mange je déménage moment camion à benne
vraiment mais les meubles enfin des
meubles le pas de buffet n'avait pas non
plus des brefs mais mes bons mais mes
objets et meubles mes trucs dans le sud
je ça a été troublant parce que c'était
un moment où justement la tournée
acoustique que j'avais faite après après
justement la grosse tournée des zéniths
et tout ça venait de se terminer et en
gros jeu c'était comme une remise à neuf
en fait je n'avais rien à faire
c'était le début de l'automne ouais j'ai
mesuré mais tout de suite en fait j'ai
parce que parce que les plaines la
nature autour de moi à la forêt derrière
moi en permanence et la solitude celle
que je retrouvais aussi je me rendais
compte aussi que j'allais pas faire de
musique tout de suite en regardant
autour de moi les premiers trucs que
j'ai vu c'est que la terre qui étaient
autour de moi les arbres etc
j'avais quelque chose à faire à
réapprendre avec mes mains en fait
j'avais à réapprendre à bricoler à
savoir bricoler ces retrouvailles là
c'est mon enfance et mon adolescence je
suis parti à 24 ans de de ce sud là et
dans ce sud là on on connaît la terre on
connaît comment nos anciens là-bas
travaillent la terre depuis toujours je
veux dire le potager ce n'est pas une
c'est pas une lubie
c'est pas un c'est pas un hobby c'est
une nécessité quand tu as la chance de
pouvoir le faire autour de toi quand tu
as la chance de pouvoir récupérer l'eau
que ce soit celle de la pluie ou celles
qui tombent sur ton toi et qui est
récupéré par des chenaux de simplement
la récupère etc j'ai recommencé à
travailler de mes mains dans plein de
domaines
à partir du moment j'ai déménagé parce
que je retrouvais un endroit un lieu que
je connaissais j'y suis né là bas
là où je vis et c'est c'est là où je
suis né et j'ai ses souvenirs voilà
d'enfance et d'adolescence oury on va
aider à faire les vendanges on connaît
ça on connaît ce cette nature qui nous
entoure et qui nous nourrit
[Musique]
elle a eu 7 7
cette force là au moment de la mort de
mon grand père qui lui était mineur à la
mines d'alès justement et qui est décédé
et à ce moment là la décidé de s'occuper
de toutes les femmes qui était veuve de
mineur et de se battre pour qu'ils aient
des droits des pensions à la hauteur
simplement voilà de pouvoir pouvoir
vivre continuer à vivre elle était
absolument féministe on peut évidemment
de dire et son son combat les
manifestations qu'elle a mené avec ses
camarades de la cgt et c'est son combat
pour obtenir des droits dans un milieu
très masculin de décideurs à l'époque
j'ai le souvenir que pendant un long
moment alors qu'elle était elle avait
déjà un certain âge formule plus jolie
balle était pas tout le temps disponible
quoi parce que elle était à la bourse du
travail à alès pour aller aider
certaines personnes à remplir leurs
papiers qui soit ne savaient pas comment
le faire pour qui les démarches était
complexe parce qu'elle était avec des
amis elle un rendez vous dans un endroit
qui s'appelle les fumades dans le sud où
elle allait danser beaucoup et c'était
des moments très précieux le féminisme
étaient présents aussi chez ma mère
c'est juste c'est à dire que quand une
femme s'engage pendant des années à
défendre les femmes battues à les
accueillir à les reloger à faire en
sorte parfois de leurs de trouver un job
dans une autre ville pour qu'elle puisse
fuir le foyer ou où c'est une rare
violence
ouais quand on entend ces conversations
quand tu sais que ta mère est en train
de faire ça que ça a fait partie de sa
vie que c'est quelque chose qui l'a
marqué à vie je sais pas comment dire
parce que tu y penses ça ne signifie
rien ce que je veux dire c'est que c'est
ça ça fait partie de toi ça fait partie
de toi